para qué valor O valores de c es x - 5
es x -5 déjame escribirlo mejor de esta
manera para
que c es x - 5 un factor
de p de X te invito a que le pongas
pausa al video e intentes hacerlo por tu
cuenta p de hecho es
p dex bien Supongo que ya lo intentaste
aquí lo que hay que darse cuenta es que
si x - 5 es un factor de p dex entonces
p dex la podemos escribir como déjame
hacer esto con un color distinto
entonces p dex lo podemos escribir como
p dex = a x - 5 que multiplica a alguna
otra cosa podemos escribir que aquí es
un polinomio un polinomio que podemos
llamar digamos gdx gdx que será un
polinomio de segundo grado entonces p de
5 tiene que ser 0 p de5 es 0 pues 5 es
una raíz de p dex aquí lo podemos ver si
aquí tomamos p de 5 este va a ser 5 - 5
y G de5 no nos importa cuánto es G de5
pero aquí tenemos 5 - 5 que es 0 así p
de5 es = 0 entonces podemos decir que si
x - 5 vamos a escribirlo aquí x - 5
es un factor de pdx sí solo sí x - 5 es
un factor si solo sí p de5 es ig a 0 Si
solo si p evaluada en 5 el polinomio
evaluado en 5 es igual a 0 entonces
hagamos p de 5 = 0 y despejemos el valor
de c p de5 es entonces 5 cubo que es 125
vamos a ponerlo aquí p de 5 es = 5 al cu
que es
125 + 2 * 5 cu 5 cu es 25 * 2 50 + 50 +
c * 5 + 5c + 10 y esto es igual a 0
ahora vamos a agrupar las constantes la
ecuación la podemos reescribir como 125
+ 50 + 10 son 175 + 10 185
185 + 5c es igual a 0 ahora restamos 185
ambos lados y nos da 5c es ig
a - 185 y dividiendo entre 5 ambos lados
tenemos que c es igual a veamos -185 /
5 -
185 / 5 veamos
180 / 5 esto Cuántas veces cabe 5 en 180
más fácil 5 * 30 es 150 nos quedan 35 35
/ 5 es 7 Así es que esto nos da
-37 - 37 está bien Esto veamos 5 * 30 50
5 * 7 35 sí efectivamente c es = a -37
ya acabamos si px = x c + 2 x cu - 37x +
10 entonces x - 5 es un factor de p
dex